[Music]
who return from their
service elsewhere the police headquarters
of the measures that we have taken
precisely so that the police
continue to keep their
administrative art and by
transport border police at the Gare du
Nord and sometimes shoot
[Music]
than the others and belongs, as in
all things, to the anti-terrorist prosecutor
who will be able to seize for the moment
he has not seized since it is the
Paris public prosecutor's office which entrusted the service
[Applause]
ferrovisions de police investigation
from  to the magistrate with high schools no
again he has no
identity papers on him here he had a
certain number of elements which
will undoubtedly allow us during the day
to identify him so
I do not know this person and
hi fonts for now but i
think in the next few hours
in the heart of the Republic
[Music]